欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这节课我们来讲一下怎样去做一个营销型的旺铺首页
旺铺首页就是我们企业的门面
一定要把你是做什么
你有什么样的优势展示出来
你能为客户解决什么样的难题
把这些优势全部展示出来
那么它的排版结构
RTS店铺可能和定制店铺是有差异化设置的
那么它所展示的内容是有所不一样的
RTS店铺和定制类的店铺
它所要呈现的能力是有一定的区别的
首先这里也是一个内容的罗列
但是不代表着按照这个顺序进行排序
我们可以自由的调整
最终我们按照自己店铺和自己这个行业的客户需求来进行排版
第一个板块就是店铺定位呈现
大概用一到三张轮廓图告诉客户自己主营产品是什么
有什么优势
我们能够为他提供什么样的服务
我们有多专业就要呈现这些
主要是提供服务
我们能够为你解决什么样的问题
第二个就是优惠券折扣券
也可以在帮户首页使用
我们的产品线
报款
这些丰富性全部展示出来
第四个就是企业的实力展示
服务能力的展示
以及如果你有合作伙伴的
那么你把那些品牌的客户案例呈现出来
这种是急剧吸引力的
特别是那些大型品牌
或者是有成功案例的那些品牌都可以
第七个就是储窗板块的设置
一般来说在首页都要设置一个储窗
因为这里有一个单独的模块可以绑定我们非常多合金的产品
第八个就是新品板块, 类目板块
这个板块可以自己选
因为这个板块的话可以自由添加的
视频营销也是一样
也是可以自由添加的
如果你有好的视频
那么建议你用上这个
前期准备我们需要准备什么呢
跟我刚才讲的那个上面的方法是一样的
是去收集同行旺铺
去看别人的内容是什么
第二个就是排版
顺序是什么
它的结构是怎么样的
你要去看
以及它的文案内容是怎么呈现怎么描述的
这些都要看
然后把这些内容排要版给到美工
我们这个首页可以做到一到三个样式
也就是一到三个样式里面
会有一到三个板块的内容
或者是文字内容不一样
去进行测试
看看它的一个效果怎么样
按照这种方式去做旺铺首页就可以了
那么我们来后台看一下具体怎么样去操作
首先我们打开这里的时候
我们要去看店铺
我们要看全球旺
旺铺点开这里
这里是不是就会有一个装修的模板
比如说产品
这是我们刚才说的产品页面
这里是公司的信息等等
这些动态
把这些全部开启
是两个新增的页面
这种的话我们一般就不用
如果是你要用的话也可以
用的话你可以展示
像旺步这个首页是一样的逻辑的
那么我们进来看一下
点击进来
编辑
编辑的话这里面会有很多很多种
这些
模块跟详情页很像
跟详情页很像
你要选哪些板块
要选哪些板块
直接按住拖过去就可以了
就可以了
那么这也是一样的
你要怎么样去呈现
你先参考别人的
把结构图
罗列出来
再按照这个逻辑去拉扯
再按照这个模块去设计就可以了
那么这样
就非常适合你去呈现了
因为这些板块一般是运营跟美工一起合作的
所以说运营要提供你的思路
内容以及你的排版的结构的构思给到
美工
让他去按照这个逻辑去做
那么你才更有可能去把一个
好的店铺旺铺首页
装修出来
最后面我们来总结一下
我们做旺铺首页
就是要把我们的
主营
产品
服务
还有专业度
全部呈现出来就可以了
你的内容可以很少
很简洁
但是你的文案
跟你的视频
还有你的图片
一定要呈现的
足够吸引人
就可以了
这个就是关于旺铺首页的装修
如果你的店铺现在
发现就是
循环转化很低
或者是旺铺首页的访客很少
那么就建议你去
按照这个思路去看看
还有没有一些改善的空间
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见